people's teachers and relatives of the
dead on their way to a memorial service
at the Yosef konak High School in the
small town of Halton they have lost 16
pupils and two teachers Germany's
President yahan gowk himself a former
Protestant pastor has come here to share
their grief cheppanu me to do this
industrial i sat there amongst all those
people and heard their sobs of loss and
grief before I came here to grieve with
them I know that we cannot bring back
those we have lost CP day no earthly
power can do that it'll the Shema
Knesset so did andreas Lubitz really
deliberately killed 149 innocent people
that's the question investigators are
facing now after the French state
prosecutor made that accusation German
police found documents at his home
proving he was suffering from a medical
condition something he was trying to
hide from his employer a doctor even
appears to have given Lubitz a sick note
for the day of the plane crash that's
prompted prosecutors to rule out
political or religious motives the
latest information follows Thursday
startling claims by french prosecutors
who accused Lubitz of deliberately
crashing the Germanwings plane into a
mountain German media reports also say
Lubitz interrupted his pilots training
six years ago to receive treatment for
severe depression investigators are
still working out what happened in the
final moments of the doomed flight which
was traveling at 700 kilometers per hour
when it crashed
automatic door OH what is clear is that
there is a mechanism to lock the cockpit
door from the inside it's designed to
protect pilots from terrorists bad
french prosecutors say it also stopped
the planes pilot re-entering the cockpit
was copilot Lubitz steered the plane
towards a mountain many European
airlines have now reacted to the
incident they've started requiring two
people to be in the cockpit at all times
that's long been the case in the United
States hi Daddy ed this VI basically
considered this idea of before I
principle as the right way to make sure
this kind of lockout situation of a
pilot cannot happen again that easily as
all I infa keep Austin cockpit this rule
may have been able to prevent the
Germanwings tragedy from happening that
threatens to worsen the grief of the
victims families